YUFENG GUO: Are you looking to
do some hyperparameter tuning
on your machine-learning model?
Or perhaps you have
other parameters
you'd like to be
optimizing in your life.
Then you've got to check out
AI Platform Optimizer, one
of the newest products
from the Google AI Team.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Welcome to AI Adventures, where
we explore the art, science,
and tools of machine learning.
My name is Yufeng Guo.
And on this episode,
we're going to dive
into the world of optimization
with AI Platform Optimizer.
The AI Platform
Optimizer was built
to optimize parameters of
machine-learning models.
So you can optimize
things like learning
rate, batch size, and other
typical machine-learning
hyperparameters.
This is the most common use
case for Optimizer today.
But wait.
There's more.
You can choose any
arbitrary values to tune.
In fact, it can optimize
any evaluable system.
For example, you could
use it to determine
the most effective combination
of background color,
font size, and link color on
a news website's subscription
button.
This would take A/B testing
to a whole new level.
Or perhaps you need to find an
ideal buffer size and thread
count to minimize computing
resources for a job.
Or maybe you need to optimize a
cookie recipe, a bread recipe,
or a brownie recipe to produce
the most delicious version.
You can, of course,
also optimize
nonfood related things, though
I'm not sure why you'd want to.
Anyhow, let's talk about
how to use the AI Platform
Optimizer to optimize your
machine-learning model
or other function.
There are three
terms that we need
to understand-- study
configurations, studies,
and trials.
A study configuration
is the definition
of the optimization problem
that you're trying to solve.
It includes the result
you would like to optimize
as well as the
parameters that affect
that result. Those are
basically the inputs that
are being optimized.
A study is the implementation
of a study configuration.
A study uses its
configuration's goal and input
parameters to conduct
experiments or trials.
So then a trial is just a
specific set of input values
that produce some
measured outcome.
AI Platform Optimizer
only suggests
input values for each trial,
but it doesn't run your trials
for you.
That is your task.
And a study will continue
until it reaches a preset limit
of trials or you end it.
So this means
that, as a service,
AI Platform Optimizer suggests
trials for you to run,
records the outcomes
of those trials,
and then uses machine learning
to suggest future trials based
on those outcomes.
And you can continue the cycle
for as long as you please.
Now, some of you may recall that
AI Platform Training already
has a built-in feature
called HyperTune, which takes
care of hyperparameter tuning.
Under the hood, HyperTune
uses the same technology
as AI Platform Optimizer.
But whereas HyperTune only
works as part of AI Platform
Training, Optimizer
is a generic system
that you can use to optimize
any system, any place.
This means that your model
could be training anywhere--
your local machine,
a data center,
or on another GCP service, like
Compute Engine or Kubernetes
Engine.
Anything that can
make a REST API call
can use AI Platform Optimizer,
and that flexibility
is its true power.
Thanks for watching this
episode of Cloud AI Adventures.
If you enjoyed it, make
sure to like the video
and subscribe to get all
the latest episodes right
when they come out.
I'm Yufeng Guo, on
Twitter @YufengG.
And if you're looking for
longer-form machine learning
and Cloud content, be sure
to check out the Adventures
in the Cloud YouTube channel,
which I've linked below
in the description.
Ready to give AI Platform
Optimizer a whirl?
Head on over to the
documentation page
I've linked to in
the description below
for all the details.
[MUSIC PLAYING]